uh the Chinese have been crossing the
median line of the Taiwan Strait in
their airplanes and also in their ships
and these are deliberate actions in
trying to destroy the status quo across
the Taiwan Strait and therefore we are
alarmed and it's not just Taiwan is
alarmed uh there are many other like
body partners of Taiwan like Japan the
United States Australia and some
European countries Canada and Etc
they're also very alarm and therefore in
their public statements they always come
in on the peace and stability over the
Taiwan Strait as being a very important
and they oppose unilateral change of
status quo so the situation is getting
worse and we need to prepare for the
worst possible scenario and does that
work possible scenario now feel more
likely yes indeed if you look at the
trajectory of the Chinese military trade
against Taiwan it is more likely but I'm
not going to pinpoint at one point or at
one year that China is going to launch a
war against Taiwan for the Chinese who
follow the traditional sins military
philosophy I think their objective right
now might try to coerce Taiwan try to
take Taiwan in without using military
force that might be their objective
right now but they might also be a point
where they might want to use military
force but no matter what Taiwan needs to
be prepared and we can anticipate that
the Chinese military pressure is going
to increase over Taiwan and therefore we
need to speed speed up our preparation
and the president has already announced
a series of military reform including
the extension of of the conscript and
that is one way to show that we are
determined and we try to get prepared
yeah I mean military figures in America
not least the head of the Navy has said
that actually an invasion as early as
this year is possible do you think
that's credible as a piece of
intelligence what there are all kinds of
predictions you know some will predict
that it would happen this year and more
will predict that they will happen next
year because someone is running for
presidential election in the United
States will also run for this
presidential election uh but somebody
says that the 2020 is more likely
somebody says 20 35 and Etc to me uh
2027 is a year that we need to watch out
it's not because of Taiwan or the United
States or other countries but because of
the uh
the situation the domestic power
situation in China in 2027 Xi Jinping is
likely to go into his fourth term
and if in his previous three terms he
cannot claim any achievement uh during
his office uh he might need to think
about something else uh for him to claim
uh his achievement or his legacy if you
look at the Chinese situation right now
the economy is going down people are not
happy the real estate business seem to
be melting down the International
Community are not happy with what China
has been doing and therefore there's
nothing for him to claim as his legacy
at this moment so we are concerned that
in 2027 if Xi Jinping cannot change the
situation domestically in China he might
want to resort to a use of force or
creating crisis externally to divert
domestic attention or to show to the
Chinese that he has accomplished
something and we are concerned that
Taiwan might become his scapegoat yeah I
mean 2022 really the dial was moved
wasn't it in terms of those military
jets uh flying towards Taiwanese
airspace you know it is now every day
they're crossing the media line every
day you could argue that the status quo
has changed they've made that an
everyday thing now what purpose do you
think
that serves for them why do you think
they're doing that is it just
intimidation is it is it part of an
early move to escalate why do you think
they are doing that uh there's several
reasons for China to do that one is for
diplomatic purpose they want to scare
away those supporters coming to support
Taiwan uh they use the pretext of
speaker Pelosi's visit to Taiwan to
launch that large-scale military
exercises to Taiwan and they want to
make their threat uh uh credible and
they want to use that to prevent other
countries from showing support to Taiwan
and the second is for military purposes
uh you know if they can come closer to
Taiwan like cross the median line of the
Talent street and come close to the 249
mile Zone I think they can suppress
taiwan's reaction time and if in the
future they want to launch a military
attack against Taiwan the response time
from Taiwan is going to be very
shortened so it has a military purpose
as well and of course the most important
will be psychological for the Taiwanese
people when we see all these Chinese
military aircrafts or Ships coming close
to Taiwan it is very threatening and the
Chinese want to threaten Taiwan into
submission so they want to you know
conquer Taiwan without using military
force to attack Taiwan so these are
possible motivations from the Chinese
side in the you know conducting military
exercises there was I mean you spray
it was a very perilous moment in August
and it felt like it really had the
potential to escalate were there moments
then that you and your colleagues in
government thought
wow this is it this is where it begins
it's really going to escalate into
something very serious now uh we
understood that it was going to escalate
escalate into a conflict but there were
still things that we need to be aware of
uh you know if it's an escalation the
two sides will move up the stairs and
the escalation might come to a point
where military Clash becomes inevitable
and we understand our responsibility
even though we have the commitment to
defend ourselves but at the same time we
don't want to see the war happening and
therefore we took a very responsible
responsible steps in the preventing the
crisis to escalate into a major crisis
that's our view at the time and we work
with the United States and other
countries to show that even though we
are very confident in defending
ourselves but at the same time we are
showing our responsibility but it must
have been very obvious to you that one
misstep and things could have really
spiraled out of control in a situation
where you couldn't control it anymore
yes in history
uh if you study War many wars happened
in ever
uh in therefore the war can happen like
an accident and if you look at the very
frequent Chinese military activities
surrounding Taiwan or the Chinese
military activities in East China Sea
and South China Sea very often you see
the sum of tiny little accent might
spark into a major war and are you
worried that that could you worry that
might happen look at the close proximity
of the Chinese airplanes and our
airplanes
and uh if they cross uh the 24 nautical
mile Zone some of our weapon systems
might have to Target those Chinese
aircrafts and that might spark an
accident uh even though it might not be
intentional for the Chinese Pilots to
cross the 24 nautical mile Zone and if
you look at the South China Sea the
Chinese airplanes sometimes will come in
very close to the petroleum airplanes by
the United States by Australia Canada
and Etc
and sometimes they are so close as close
as 10 feet away and sometimes they will
fly flares to scare away the patrol boat
and these are all very dangerous and
provocative actions and they might Spark
accidental War
yeah is there anything you can do to
prevent that at this stage uh
the only thing to prevent that is you
know our self-restraint we want to show
our responsible way of handling this but
the second most effective way is for the
International Community to tell China
that what they have been doing is
untolerable and for the International
Community especially the like-minded
democracies to tell China that they need
to look at the peace and stability over
the Taiwan Strait as a very important
matter and they should also tell China
that any new individual change of status
quo is not going to be accepted and
fortunately we are seeing the federal
democracies beginning to say that to
China and if all democracies are
committed to peace sensibility over this
area I think China needs to think twice
when they want to spark any accident
there are some analysts who say that
militarily Taiwan is underprepared for a
potential war with China there are some
saying that you don't have enough
Munitions that defense spending as a
proportion of GDP is not high enough
that there are not enough recruits into
the army that there's not enough focus
on isometric Warfare and all these
things and and some say that actually
Taiwan is significantly less prepared
than Ukraine was to offer a similar
example is it a fair accusation that
Taiwan is being complacent in the face
of this threat uh there's always room to
Improvement for improvement and we
understand that and we try to improve
our preparedness and our capability to
self-defense we understand that in
previous years we might not have
acquired sufficient ammunition and in
previous previous years we might not
have sufficient training for our
military personnel and in previous years
we understand that the number of our
soldiers in defending Taiwan might not
be enough but look at the reform
measures the president has announced we
try to buy more weapons from the United
States we want to to produce more
domestically
for your information you know taiwan's
military industry is rather strong and
therefore we want to use that advantage
to produce a lot of weapons for our for
our own purposes and we also announced
the extension of the conscripts from
four months to one year and we have also
announced that we are going to tighten
up the training process for the
transcripts and I think all these shows
at Taiwan is trying to get prepared and
also one thing for you to know that we
are working together with like-minded
Partners so that taiwan's military
personnel can be better prepared can be
better trained and that kind of process
is going on and we are very happy with
the train right now do you think it
would be possible for Taiwan to
withstand an invasion or a blockade from
the pla without direct intervention from
the United States
our uh you know expression on this has
been very consistent
is that defending Taiwan it's our own
responsibilities and if we are not
willing to defend ourselves we have no
right to ask any other country for help
and would you be able to without that
help we are determined to defend
ourselves and we will defend ourselves
and we will have the ability to defend
ourselves and look at the training and
the acquisition of Munitions and Etc we
have the confidence that we will be able
to defend ourselves even though
comparatively a lot of countries are
saying that Taiwan is so small China is
so big and China is so powerful would
Taiwan be able to withstand the answer
of the Chinese immigration I think the
same comparison can be put on Ukraine
Russia you know Ukraine is relatively
weak but Russia is one of the largest
military in the world and people
anticipate that you Ukraine will fall
within a week or two but they continue
to fight on because they adopted the
right strategy and they show their
morale in determination by the same
token Taiwan will do the same thing we
will be able to defend ourselves
your government was
the basis of maintaining the status quo
not pushing for Independence not
conceding to China is the status quo
really just a temporary stop Gap you
know can the status quo really last
forever
uh it might not last forever but the
status quo can be maintained if both
sides show respect to that status quo uh
and our policies that that status quo
serves the best interest for all parties
concerned and therefore the policy of
this government is is going to continue
this policy of safeguarding the status
quo but if the Chinese
especially their military uh decides
that they will have the power to upset
the status quo of course the status quo
is going to be very hard to maintain and
look at what China is trying to do right
now they are trying to Upstate the State
score and then create new normal and
it's going to be a lot of pressure and
it's going to be dangerous uh for all
the countries in this region and
therefore the International Community
should advise China or should urge China
that they need to keep the status quo as
well in order to maintain peace
sensibility in this area I mean
relations as you said have really
deteriorated in the last year under your
government I mean is there more that the
government of Taiwan could do to talk to
China to try and de-escalate the
situation we're currently in uh we are
trying and if you listen very carefully
to either the president or other senior
government officials we are open to
talks with China
and if the Chinese are willing to talk
to Taiwan the door is always opened uh
but we don't welcome political
preconditions of course but the Chinese
are making it very clear on their
political preconditions they set the
tone in January on January 2nd 2019 in
XI jinping's very famous statement they
said that we have to accept One China
principle we have to accept unification
we have to accept one country to such a
model after Hong Kong do you still want
us to accept one country to System model
you know we are not out of our mind and
therefore accepting those Chinese
preconditions means that we are
submitting to China and that is
something that the people here in Taiwan
would never accept but our door is open
if China wants to speak with Taiwan
honestly to deal with the differences in
between the two sides we are open to
that kind of suggestion but setting
political precondition is not acceptable
does that path though to de-escalation
now feel pretty blocked off because of
recent actions uh
I would say that Taiwan would try not to
escalate
Taiwan will not provoke and Taiwan
government would not give China any
excuse to launch a war against Taiwan
and that is one of the most responsible
way that Taiwan can do in its policy and
we are doing it right now and I think
the responsibilities on the other side
you can see that China is a flexing its
military muscle and Taiwan trying to
prevent Taiwan from participating in
international Affairs criticizing Taiwan
in an undeserved Manner and it's being a
very provocative and I think the
International Community should
recommend to China that they should act
like a responsible member of the
International Community